Do you want to have sex?
Love, I've just had a big dinner
and it's one in the morning.
You still enjoy having sex with
me?
Absolutely yes.
As much as you used to?
-Yes.
-Wow!
I've seen the film before so I'm
not on the edge of my seat.
But it's still my favorite of
all time.
You don't have kids?
We have actually been trying for
kids for a while now.
With your complications,
conceiving is very unlikely.
So what do we do now?
A small piece of us dies and we
just carry on with whatever's
left.
Alright, well as long as
we've got a plan.
I think I'm ready to talk about
adopting.
You gotta be careful with
adoption.
Mel from the club got a rescue
dog, shat everywhere.
I don't know what I'm supposed
to do with that information.
(Music)
We need to convince people
that we're great.
And they're gonna judge us.
(Music)
We should make a list of all the
flaws that we wanna iron out.
You drink too much.
You should stop smoking.
You need to get stronger
emotionally.
You need to work on your anger.
I think we're gonna be amazing
parents.
(pop)
It is not a test, I am on your
side.
This is about preparing you for
panel.
So, how often would you say you
have sex?
It's a scary business.
My kids are vampires that suck
every ounce of energy out of me
until I'm nothing but an empty
carcass.
Other than that you're alright?
Yea.
(Music)
Change, it's a bit scary.
But you can't get too attached
to what you think your life's
gonna be.
Love you.
I love you.
Even like this?
I love you more like that.
Oh for God's sake.
Do you know how lucky you are?
They are tiny little miracles.
Your 17 twitter followers can
wait.
Talk to your children!
They're not my children!
-So sorry.
-I'm calling the police.
We can't get a criminal record.
They won't give us a kid.
Sorry mate, we're not bad people
it's just it's just very
complicated.
(Music)